my parents to know that I love them no
matter what and I'm sorry for
disappointing them there was nothing
disappointing about Jeremiah Lloyd
Harmons performance on Sundays American
Idol has the 26 year old singer vied for
a spot in the top 20 it's been a really
difficult past few months for me well my
parents still have not been able to
accept me being gay I'm no longer
working as a janitor at my dad's Church
Jeremiah explained his song choice
Fleetwood Mac's landslide he said he
really connected with it after having a
tough conversation with his parents
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
broaden the
the judges loved Jeremiah's performance
he even got a little choked up when he
got offstage
good news Jeremiah is in the top 20 but
even more touching his heart-to-heart
with Katy Perry one pastor's kid to
another can you imagine when my first
single was I kissed a girl and my
parents reacted it was difficult for me
because I felt very alone
I see you and I love you and I accept
you in case you couldn't tell by Katie's
fabulously festive ensemble this round
of auditions was filmed in Hawaii not
exactly a bad day at the office
he joined the judges in Paradise now
with this season are you guys judging
differently are you coming into it with
a different approach having a year
behind you you understand when you may
want to give somebody maybe one more
opportunity and sometimes even last year
some kids we let them through based on
their original audition well now this
year we know they're gonna get chewed up
there's no need to prolong
[Music]